défi communiste ou communisants vérité
d'hommes semblables limbo
bonjour et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
chronique de scopeo je m'appelle lucas
et je vous propose aujourd'hui d'écouter
le deuxième épisode de notre série de
podcasts intitulé à la racine des idées
cette série vise à analyser et à
décortiquer des ouvrages politiques ou
philosophiques pour cette chronique
aujourd'hui il sera question du livre
titré la désobéissance civile de henry
david thoreau
mais avant toute chose commençons par
adresser une brève présentation de cet
auteur henry david thoreau est un
philosophe et poète américain du 19e
siècle
il est également présentée comme
naturaliste en ce sens qu'il a publiés
l'un de ses ouvrages majeurs entrer dans
la postérité valdan ou la vie dans les
bois en 1854
il y fait l'éloge de la vie simple et
éthiques synonyme d'une proximité
retrouver avec la nature est il écrit
d'ailleurs ce texte après avoir vécu
dans une cabane en pleine forêt
la pensée écologiste moderne voit cet
ouvrage de taureau comme le roman le
plus symbolique dans la critique du
monde occidental
elle appelle à un retour à la nature on
retrouve ici une sorte de conscience
environnementale naissante
l'autre ouvrage majeur publié par henry
david thoreau qui fera ici l'objet d'une
analyse fidèle au plus près du texte et
son essai d'abord paru en 1849
sous le titre de résistance au
gouvernement civil et renommé plus tard
la désobéissance civile
le point de départ de ce pamphlet dont
de grands résistants pacifique reprenant
la non violence telle que gandhi et
luther king s'inspireront plus tard
repose sur le refus de taureaux de payer
ses impôts au gouvernement américain
notamment à cause de sa politique
esclavagiste et de sa guerre de conquête
mené au mexique qui se traduit par des
annexions de territoire on peut tracer
un lien de parenté évident avec un autre
texte fondateur portant sur la nécessité
de désobéir à l'autorité politique non
légitime écrit par le poète français
etienne de la boétie au xvième siècle le
fameux discours sur la servitude
volontaire ainsi dans la droite ligne de
cette pensée philosophique marqué par la
résistance politique dans la droite
ligne de la maxime soyez donc résolu de
ne plus servir et vous serez libre
toro prolonge ce concept de
désobéissance passive permettant de
briser les chaînes de la domination est
construit la notion de désobéissance
civile toujours très en vogue
aujourd'hui la notion de désobéissance
civile implique ainsi le refus assumé et
public de se soumettre à une loi un
règlement à une organisation ou un
pouvoir politique jugée inique et non
légitime par ceux qui le contestent tout
en faisant de ce refus une arme
pacifique et non violente
elle se distingue ainsi de la révolte
classique et traditionnelle qui exigent
de recourir à la violence pour l'opposer
à la violence dénoncé du pouvoir
politique
il est temps désormais de se plonger
dans la pensée de henry david thoreau
pour saisir la nature et la légitimation
du processus de désobéissance civile
[Musique]
toro démarre son pamphlet par une devise
claire et limpide le meilleur
gouvernement est celui qui gouverne le
moins un appel criant de liberté peut
être même les prémices de la pensée
politique libertarienne pour rappel les
militants libertariens sont favorables à
une réduction voire à la disparition
totale de l'état en tant que système
fondé sur la coercition au profit plutôt
d'une coopération libre et volonté entre
les individus
avec 1 et à limiter à des fonctions
strictement régaliennes en somme une
structure étatique dont l'étendue est
limité au maximum
il va même plus loin en prolongeant
cette maxime et on a déployant en ces
termes le meilleur gouvernement est
celui qui ne gouverne pas du tout il est
clair pour tous que l'autorité politique
doit être entièrement rejeté
l'auteur présente ensuite des objections
que l'on peut opposer au principe
d'armée permanente qui sont en fait les
mêmes que l'on peut opposer aux
principes de gouvernement permanent
le penseur américain réaffirme l'idée
que le gouvernement n'est qu'un moyen
choisi par un peuple pour exécuter sa
volonté est que celui-ci donc est
susceptible de se tromper et d'être
perverti avant que le peuple qui l'a élu
puisse réagir
il prend ainsi comme exemple la guerre
menée en son temps contre lé mexique et
le processus d'annexion des territoires
mexicains qui sont l'oeuvre selon lui
d'un nombre restreint d'individus qui se
servent du gouvernement permanent comme
d'un outil personnel car le peuple
n'aurait pas consenti à cette mesure
toro va même plus loin en dénonçant la
supposée incompétence de gouvernement
américain son incapacité à favoriser la
moindre initiative
ils l'accusent même de ne pas conserver
la liberté du pays de ne pas pacifié
l'ouest de ne pas instruire son peuple
tout ce que le peuple américain a
réalisé il ne le doit ainsi qu'à
lui-même qu'à ses propres
accomplissements et il doit saisir ainsi
que le gouvernement lui fait même
parfois obstacle
mais
c'est
dans sa dénonciation du pouvoir
politique se joint également une
critique de l' entrave aux échanges et
aux commerces
en effet henry david thoreau dénonce des
obstacles que leur imposent 116 les
législateurs ceci devrait ainsi selon
lui être puni avec les êtres malfaiteurs
qui font dérailler les trains selon ses
propres mots l'écrivain s'inscrit ici
dans la tradition libérale de l'éloge du
libre échange de la libre concurrence
non faussée par la suite il nuance son
propos il se détache de la critique
purement libertaire et précise qu'il
n'est pas par principe anti
gouvernementales
il réclame ainsi je le cite non une
absence immédiate de gouvernement mais
immédiatement un meilleur gouvernement
et pour ce faire il invite chaque
secteur chaque citoyen a exprimé qu'elle
serait l'ultime de gouvernement qui
respecterait et imaginerait être le
meilleur taureau défend l'idée d'un rôle
actif du peuple pour que le citoyen
abandonnent plus sa conscience aux seuls
législateur ainsi la loi imposée par le
gouvernement ne doit pas nécessairement
être accepté par le citoyen car la seule
obligation que j'ai le droit d'adopter
c'est d'agir à tout moment selon ce qui
me paraît juste dans l'héritage de la
boétie le poète américain affirme ici
que la loi n'a jamais rendu les hommes
plus juste d'un iota et à cause du
respect qu'il lui marc les êtres bien
disposés eux mêmes deviennent les agents
de l'injustice selon ses propres mots
ces mots sont forts au lieu de rendre
les hommes meilleurs et la société plus
juste
la loi pourrait selon toro produit à
l'exacte effet inverse en pervertissant
les citoyens qui la respectent à la
lettre
pour illustrer ce propos selon lequel la
loi ne rend pas nécessairement les
hommes meilleurs
il choisit notamment l'exemple des
soldats des colonels des capitaines bref
celui de l'armée pour expliquer que bien
souvent ces citoyens agissent contre
leur propre gré et marche verte des
guerres qu'ils ne souhaitent pas ces
militaires respectent les ordres de la
hiérarchie contre leur propre conscience
mènent des combats et des horreurs dont
ils savent la portée mais puisqu'ils ont
progressivement été vidés de leur
substance d'hommes
dispose sans broncher cet exemple de
l'armée perverti par les ordres et de
cette masse d'hommes qui sert l'état
aveuglément résonne encore plus dans nos
esprits contemporains
après que le xxème siècle nous en est
donnée malheureusement les illustrations
les plus barbares
[Musique]
je dois maintenant vous lire ce passage
essentiel qui suit et qui résume toute
l'entreprise de déshumanisation employés
par l'autorité de l'état sur ses
citoyens sur la perte de sens moral et
sur la nécessité de résister ouvrez les
guillemets la masse des hommes sert
l'état de la sorte pas en tant qu'homme
mais comme des machines avec leur corps
ils forment l'armée de métier ainsi que
la milice léger ollier les policiers etc
dans la plupart des cas il n'existe
aucun libre exercice du jugement ou du
sens moral mais il se met au même niveau
que le bois la terre et les pierres et
l'on pourrait réaliser des hommes de
bois qui remplirait aussi bien cette
fonction il ne mérite pas plus de
respect que des épouvantails ils ont la
même valeur que des chevaux ou des
chiens
pourtant ce sont de tels êtres qu'on
juge communément de bons citoyens
d'autres comme la plupart des
législateurs politiciens juriste
ministres fonctionnaires servent l'état
surtout avec leur tête
et comme ils font rarement à la moindre
distinction moral il risque tout autant
de servir le diable sans en avoir
l'intention que dieu un tout petit
nombre héros patriote martyrs
réformateurs au sens fort des hommes
enfin servent l'état avec leur
conscience
aussi il lui résiste nécessairement pour
l'essentiel et il les traite souvent en
ennemis fermez les guillemets dans ce
long passage toro fait expressément
appelle au libre arbitre du citoyen à la
résistance menés par la conscience de
l'homme contre l'état pour faire preuve
de sagesse pour ne plus être considérés
comme de simples marionnettes ou des
chiens pour reprendre ses termes
l'homme doit se libérer de l'emprise
immoral de l'état pour ne plus lui être
possédé et pour ainsi célébré sa liberté
ensuite henry david thoreau se montre
très critique à l'endroit du pouvoir
politique américain et ne le reconnaît
tout simplement pas comme son
gouvernement puisqu'il est aussi le
gouvernement de l'esclave puisque tous
les hommes admettre le droit à la
révolution selon lui le droit de refuser
l'allégeance au gouvernement et de lui
résister quand sa tyrannie ou son
inefficacité sont grandes et
insupportable il faut selon lui réalisé
que tel était le cas à son époque
car je le cite un sixième de la
population d'une nation ayant vocation
d'être le refuge de la liberté sont des
esclaves ils alertent ici sur l'urgence
de se rebeller et d'entamer une
révolution pacifique contre le
gouvernement américain oppresseurs à la
fois contre les millions d'esclaves mais
aussi il le rappelle contre les
mexicains envahi par son armée
[Musique]
pour insister sur le caractère moral de
la désobéissance civile toro assimile de
façon manichéenne le vote a un jeu un
choix entre le juste d'un côté et
l'injuste de l'autre ainsi si mon idée
de la justice ne l'emportent pas par le
vote
peu importe j'accepte de m'en remettre
la décision de la majorité
il est donc d'un grand hasard finalement
que la justice l'emportent par le vote
d'autant plus que toro souligne qu il y
a peu de vertu dans l'action des masses
d'hommes donc l'homme qui s'en remet aux
votes langue à jamais sa propre liberté
s'ils votent pour la justice ils se
contentent simplement d'exprimer un
faible désir de l'avoir prévaloir dès
lors si l'homme veut voir régner la
justice s'il veut notamment à thé
l'abolition de l'esclavagé
il doit s'engager lui-même bien plus que
par le simple vote
il doit engager sa propre liberté il
précise tout de même ensuite que le
devoir d'un homme n'est pas
naturellement de se vouer à
l'éradication de la moindre injustice
fut-elle énorme
il est tout à fait normal compréhensible
que l'homme et d'autres sujets d'intérêt
en revanche il est de son devoir tour où
la firme de ne pas donner son soutien à
l'injustice et de ne pas se consacrer à
des loisirs au détriment d'autrui pour
quincy autrui puisse aussi se consacrer
à ses loisirs et à ses intérêts dans ce
cadre tout au long de son pamphlet toro
fait l'éloge de la justice c'est le
coeur de ce qui doit motiver la
désobéissance civile je le cite si votre
voisin vous vol d'un seul dollar
vous ne vous contentez pas de savoir
qu'on vous a trompé de le dire
voir de lui réclamer votre dû mais vous
prenez des mesures pratiques pour
récupérer la somme totale et veiller à
ne plus jamais l'être agir à partir du
principe qu'on prendrait accomplir la
justice cela change les choses et les
relations celle ci est essentiellement
révolutionnaire et ne correspond à rien
de ce qui a pu être elle ne divise pas
seulement les états où les églises
elle divise les familles allons plus
loin elle divise l'individu et ses
parents lui le diabolique du divin
[Musique]
le penseur américain attributs ici à la
justice une dimension quasiment sacré
est absolument nécessaire si l'homme
entend agir pour le bien il doit
accomplir la justice dans ses actes et
non plus seulement dans ses paroles ou
encore dans son vote
il doit ainsi au quotidien non plus
obéir aveuglément aux lois injustes mais
tâchez de les amender et de les
transgresser
il n'est plus question d'attendre de
convaincre la majorité pour désobéir à
l'injustice du gouvernement
la minorité de sage comme l'appelle toro
doit pousser à la réforme doit signaler
au gouvernement ses fautes pour le
conduire à mieux faire car pour l'auteur
à travers l'histoire de l'humanité le
pouvoir politique se trouve trop
fréquemment dans le corps d'injustice je
le cite
pourquoi crucifix est il toujours le
christ excommunie t-il toujours copernic
et lutter déclare-t-il les rebelles de
washington et les franklyn ainsi si la
machine du gouvernement selon ses mots
fait de nous un agent de l'injustice
toro déclare qu'il est de notre devoir
d'enfreindre la loi afin de ne pas se
prêter au mal que le condamne pour
revenir à l'importance de ne pas
attendre de convaincre la majorité pour
agir contre l'injustice de l'état le
penseur américain conseille à ceux qui
se baptisent abolitionniste de retirer
sur le champ leur soutien effectif et
personnelle au gouvernement du
massachusetts qui maintient la pratiques
esclavagistes
il n'est pas question d'attendre de
former une majorité de personnes
il est question de faire triompher la
justice pour illustrer ce propos il
tient ensuite une formule saisissante
je le cite six mille ou cent ou dix
hommes disons même si un seul homme
honnête dans cet état du massachusetts
cessant de détenir des esclaves se
retire est effectivement de ce
partenariat et était en conséquence
enfermé dans la prison du comté
cela sonnerait la position de l'
esclavage en amérique ici toro encourage
l'action de chaque citoyen en expliquant
qu'un seul résistant qu'un seul
désobéissants au pouvoir peut faire
évoluer les choses
il importe avant tout de commencer et de
ne plus se contenter de parler ou de
voter
qu'importe la menace d'être emprisonné
de reprendre a su risque lui-même en
refusant de payer l'impôt
la prison est selon lui un lieu libre et
honorable pour les esprits les moins
servile
en ce sens que le fait d'y être placé
permet de ne plus être avec l'état mais
contre lui
[Musique]
le
ainsi on le voit tout au long de son
discours toro appel à l'action à la
désobéissance civile dans les actes car
une minorité est impuissante tant
qu'elles se conforment à la majorité ce
n'est du reste plus une minorité mais
elle devient irrésistible quand elle l'a
bloc de tout son poids
ils donnent bien entendu des moyens
d'action comme le fait justement de
refuser de payer ses impôts car je le
cite le fait de les payer et permettre
par la l'état de commettre la violence
et de verser le sang innocent il appelle
donc à la non-violence à une révolution
paisible selon ses termes si semblables
chose est possible
l'entreprise de désobéissance consiste
ainsi pour le citoyen a refusé son
allégeance au gouvernement pour que in
fine et le fonctionnaires démissionnent
ainsi la révolution sera accompli sur la
nécessité de payer l'impôt à l'état pour
recevoir de l'ue en échange la sécurité
et la tranquillité publique
henry david thoreau n'apprécie pas
l'idée qu'il s'en remettent parfois à la
protection de l'état puisque s'il réfute
l'autorité de l'état lorsqu'il présente
sa feuille d'impôts je le cite l'état ne
tardera pas à prendre et à détruire tout
mais bien à me arras est ce enfin moi et
mes enfants
cela est faux ce pénible cela interdit
un homme de vivre nos honnêtement et
confortablement à la fois l'auteur
accuse ici la mainmise de l'autorité
étatique sur la vie du citoyen sa
propension à s'accaparer les biens et
les richesses de l'homme sous prétexte
de lui assurer une protection
ainsi dans ce rejet de l'état toureau
explique il ne sert à rien d'accumuler
des biens
puisqu'on ne manquerait pas de les
perdre et qu'il vaut mieux ainsi trouvé
un refuge quelque part cultiver une
petite récolte et se hâter de la manger
il encourage ici le fait de vivre en
autarcie de ne dépendre que de soi et
d'être toujours prêt à lever le camp
sans avoir beaucoup en emporter je n'ai
pas besoin de la protection de l'état
pour ma propre sécurité
si je vis éloigné de lui si je me
consacre à construire un domaine chez
moi par des moyens paisible c'est je
tiens à ce que ma liberté ne soit pas
menacée par l'état ainsi je puis me
permettre de refuser l'allégeance au
gouvernement civil et son droit summa
bourse et ma vie ainsi pour toro cela me
coûterait moins dans tous les sens
d'encourir le châtiment de la
désobéissance vis-à-vis de l'état que de
lui obéir
selon ses propres termes
toro défend explicitement la vie en
dehors de l'autorité de l'état
on retrouve sous sa plume une ode à la
liberté synonyme selon lui de vie
autarcique indépendante et autonome
[Musique]
ce pamphlet devient ensuite un peu plus
autobiographique et décrit l'expérience
personnelle de désobéissance civile de
taureaux je vous lis ce passage
éclairant ouvrez les guillemets jeunes
et paient aucun impôt local depuis six
ans on m'a mis en prison une fois pour
cette raison une nuit et comme je
regardais les murs de pierres massives
épais de deux ou trois pieds la porte de
bois et de fer épaisse d'un pied la
grille de fer qui a altéré la lumière je
ne pouvais m'empêcher d'être frappé par
la stupidité de cette institution qui me
traitaient comme si je n'étais rien que
chez réhausse enfermé je m'étonnais
qu'elle ait fini par conclure que
c'était le meilleur usage qu'elles
pouvaient faire de moi et qu'elle n'ait
jamais songé à profiter de mes services
de quelque autre manière je voyais bien
que s'il y avait un mur de pierres entre
moi et mes concitoyens il y en avait 1
d'encore plus difficile à percer avant
qu'il puisse être aussi libre que moi
l'auteur tourne au ridicule la décision
du gouvernement de l'enfermer déclarant
qu'il ne se sentait aucunement les trois
derrière ce vaste gâchis de pierres et
de ciment expliquant que l'état se
trompait en estimant que son désir était
de rester de l'autre côté du mur
il dénonce ici l'imbécilité du
gouvernement la crainte que lui
inspirait un esprit libre comme celui de
taureaux et souligne que c'est parce que
l'état ne pouvait l'atteindre dans sa
raison qu'il décida de châtier son corps
montrant ainsi que le gouvernement ne
pouvait plus faire la différence entre
ses amis et ses ennemis intérieurs
il déclare je le cite je perdis le peu
de respect que je gardais pour lui et le
plaignant ce qui est intéressant dans ce
récit est dans cette vision des choses
c'est que toro souligne que l'état ne
s'adresse jamais à la raison de l'homme
à son intellect à sa morale mais choisit
plutôt de s'attaquer à son corps et à
ses sens en faisant preuve de répression
physique
il dit que l'état n'est pas armé d'un
esprit ou d'une honnêteté supérieur mais
d'une force physique supérieure cet
essai explique ainsi que la légitimité
politique de l'état repose sur la seule
force et la contrainte mais sur aucune
supériorité morale ou intellectuelles
henry david thoreau conclu son ouvrage
par un rappel celui enseignée par
etienne de la boétie quelques siècles
plus tôt la légitimité de l'état
n'existe que parce que les citoyens lui
concède
il dit je le cite l'autorité du
gouvernement même si elle est telle que
j'accepte de me soumettre
car j'obéirai blondy à ceux qui en
savent plus que moi ils font mieux que
moi reste un pur pour être strictement
juste elle doit posséder l'agrément et
le consentement des gouvernés
elle ne peut avoir de droit absolu sur
ma personne et la propriété
sinon ce que je lui concède il conclut
son propos en prenant l'exemple du
philosophe chinois qui même lui tient
l'individu comme le fondement de lempire
la démocratie n'est donc que le juste
respect du citoyen néanmoins il se pose
ces interrogations
la démocratie telle que nous la
connaissons est elle la dernière
amélioration possible à un gouvernement
n'est-il pas possible d'aller plus loin
dans la reconnaissance et l'organisation
des droits de l'homme selon taureau pour
que l'état soit vraiment libre et
éclairé il doit reconnaître et traiter
l'individu comme un pouvoir indépendant
d'où proviennent son propre pouvoir et
son autorité sur les hommes
par conséquent si la légitimité du
gouvernement émane des individus il doit
être juste envers tous les hommes est
traitée l'individu respectueusement
[Musique]
ainsi la désobéissance civile est sans
aucun doute l'un des textes fondateurs
de la contestation sociale à travers le
monde qui suivra sa publication comme
celui de la boétie c'est un texte qui ne
semble jamais prendre une ride et qui
continuera d'inspirer des générations de
résistants et d'insoumis prenant la non
violence entre l'autorité politique
malheureusement pour lui henry david
thoreau qui meurt en 1862 ne vivra pas
assez longtemps pour connaître
l'abolition de l'esclavagé dans son pays
qui était si chère à ses yeux pour voir
le règne de la justice qui plus est dans
le processus d'abolition qui se
déroulera il n'y aura aucune
pacification tel qu'ils le souhaitaient
mais elle se déroulera dans le feu et
dans le sang la suite de la guerre
civile nommé guerre de sécession
en tout cas tour oppose de nombreuses
interrogations qui méritent d'être
toujours méditer dans cet essai comme
une société juste peut-être s'accommoder
de l'asservissement d'être en tout point
ego le plus grand bien du plus grand
nombre peut-il reposer sur le malheur
absolu d'un petit nombre
puis je me contentais d'un sort
confortable quand je sais qu'ils
prospèrent sur l'exploitation d'autres
hommes
à toutes ces questions tour prend le
parti de la justice par ailleurs
certains propos peuvent faire écho à l
ouvrage majeur d'alexis de tocqueville
de la démocratie en amérique
lorsqu'elle se demande si la loi de la
majorité est nécessairement démocratique
et si la loi décidée par le législateur
est forcément juste et acceptable
le gouvernement majoritaire est devenu
synonyme de justice
or selon soro la loi de la majorité ne
saurait trouver de justification que si
elle rime avec la loi de la justice
enfin l'avenir lui donnera raison
lorsqu'il affirme qu'un seul homme juste
emprisonné par l'état pourraient avoir
raison d'une politique injuste comme
avec gandhi pionnier de la désobéissance
civile
chivu rat raison de la puissance d'un
empire au 20e siècle
pour cette cause je suis tout comme vous
prêt à mourir mais écoutez mes amis il
n'existe aucune cause au monde pour
laquelle je me sens prêt à tuer quoi
qu'il nous fasse nous n'attaquerons
personne nous ne tuerons personne mais
nous ne donnerons pas nos empreintes
personne n'acceptera de le faire ils
nous mettront en prison ils nous feront
payer des amendes
ils saisiront nos biens mais ce qu'ils
ne réussiront pas à nous prendre par la
force c'est notre dignité